what do you make of David's favorite
sighting of the Tic Tac UFO and other
pilots who have uh seen these objects
that seem to defy the laws of physics
well I think
you have to take them at their word
um are they fascinating to you
absolutely no I know I know a lot of
these people right so I I know Lou
Elizondo Chris melon the whole crowd
I've been I I saw the videos about three
weeks or so before they went public
I was um at a bar with Lou overlooking
the Pentagon in Crystal City and they
showed him to me and my hair stood on
end and he said he said this is he said
this is coming out soon and I I know one
of the guys on the inside who was the
naval intelligence who had interviewed
all of these Pilots again before this
came out and it was hair raising to hear
this uh but also exciting that you know
here's not just people's testimony these
are credible individuals and if you've
seen the 60 Minute episode with uh some
of the pilots uh you know they have no
monetary gain if anything they've got
negative gain uh from coming out but
then you also have all of those
simultaneous uh
ship analysis from the USS Princeton and
the radar analysis Etc
so
um you know at the end of the day it's
just data it's not a conclusion
um I'm I'd be perfectly happy honestly
perfectly happy if somebody showed that
it was all a hoax
I can go back to my day job
right that could be a hoax but other
things might not be I mean right this is
the point I mean what this is why it's
nice to remove
some of the stigma about this topic
because it's all just data and
uh and anomalous events are such that
there's going to be they're going to be
rare in terms of how much data they
represent but we have to consider the
full range of data to discover the
things that actually represent something
that's uh if we pull at it we'll
discover something that's
extraterrestrial or something
deep about the phenomena on Earth that
we don't yet understand right well if it
only stimulates people for instance to
think okay well what happens if we could
move like that with momentum-less
movement
and and it stimulates
young individuals to go into the
Sciences to ask those questions that to
me is fascinating I mean after I've been
openly talking about this in the last
year especially
I've had a number of uh students from
top schools who aren't my students come
to me and say
if I can help
let me how can I help I never had
thought about this before but you opened
you and others not just you and others
have opened my mind to thinking about
this matter yeah that's why it's
actually funny that uh Elon Musk doesn't
think too much about this
uh these kinds of proportional systems
that could defy the laws of physics as
we currently understand them
to me it's a powerful way to think what
what is possible
it's uh it's inspiring even if somebody
doesn't represent uh extraterrestrial
vehicles I think the the observation
itself it's like uh something you
mentioned which is uh you know
hypothesizing imagining these things
considering the possibility of these
things I think opens up your mind in a
way that um ultimately can create the
technology first you have to believe the
technology is possible before you can
create it
in my own lab you know we always look
for as I've said before what is
inevitable
and you know saying inevitably this is
the kind of data we need but if we need
that kind of data the instrument we want
isn't doesn't exist okay so I imagine
the perfect instrument I can't make it
and you back into something which is
practical and then you in a sense
reverse engineer the future of what it
is that you want to make and I've
started and sold like at least half a
dozen or more companies
using that basic premise
and so it was always something that
didn't exist today but we imagined what
we wanted
and at the time many people said it
couldn't be done I mean for instance all
the gene therapy that's done today was
retroviruses
came from a group meeting in David
Baltimore's lab I was a postdoc with him
and one of the other post-docs wasn't
able to you make retroviruses in a way
that he wanted to and I realized I had a
cell line that would allow us to make
retroviruses in two days rather than two
months
and so he and I then worked together to
make that system and now all gene
therapy with retroviruses is done using
this basic approach around the whole
world because something couldn't be done
and we wanted to do it better
and we imagined the future
and so that's I think
what the whole UFO phenomenon is doing
for people it's like well let's imagine
a future
where these kinds of Technologies are
but also let's imagine a future where we
don't blow ourselves up right so if
these things are there they managed to
not blow themselves up
so it means that at least one other
civilization got past the inflection
point